教你做全台灣第一個領到股息的人
知感謝
哎呦感謝狗
推廣除全息
我是全台灣6月份
第一個領股息的男人
6月1號上8點30分
現金鼓勵是19萬
除全息就這麼迷人
重點我們是要找除全息日
榮譽長的標準
怎麼做到的咧
像XXXXXX
當天開高的機率87%
沒有再更高了
小哥你看我今天第一次錄影穿外套
為什麼
因為我冷
因為我們有一個有點遜的公司
對啊
本來有爆一堆
我也有爆
本來我都可以去入主了
結果之前殺很多
還是要停損掉
停損掉一些啦
對
我沒賺
然後有一次跟你
算一算好像我也沒賺
有一次跟你和谷魚聊天
難得兩位鐵口直段有志一統
我就把它除掉了
就覺得那個
股東會行情應該結束了嘛
結果最近好強還漲停
現在是卸票行情
卸票行情
這麼早就卸票了
對啊
那麼晚卸
早點卸不是很好嗎
早點卸害我們都把它
早點卸我們一堆股票的時候
幹嘛不卸
對啊 所以那個有點訊
已經不是有點訊了
對 現在叫有硬
有點硬
真是的 很討厭
所以今天我們不能
騰棋太晚了
我們不能再輸了
我們今天也要更早
要更早
好 所以今天的理財大人秀
歌有仇必報
我們看到終於又是
小哥跟趙華一對一
很多網友敲碗說
只想看到小哥跟趙華
兩個人
我也是希望兩個人
两个人可以讲得比较
比较深入
深入浅出
我们刚才讨论说有的股票
你觉得你太晚进场了
或者是说有些股息
你太晚才能领到了
小哥今天的主题
非常的火辣
怎么说呢
他要教你做全台湾如何
第一个领到除全息股息的人
第一个领到
太难了吧
不会啦
这个主题也太强悍了
很强悍
全台湾第一个领到股息的人
這個主題之前
我要先來感謝一下
我們來看一下
知感謝古瑜老師
古瑜老師大德推廣除泉洗
雖然我開始玩除泉洗的時候
他應該跟我差不多時間開始玩了
我們都玩得滿早的
他還在那邊當工程師
還在穿他的無塵服
可是我們這樣推廣下去
很多人來玩
對
除菲璧璧的投資優點
造福相禮 功德無量
這個會讓我們以後玩除菲璧璧
比較好玩一點
因為他都叫大家抱著不要罵
對
所以大家籌碼很穩定
相信他的人
就會讓我們的籌碼穩定
對
我們是喜歡做短的
我們做短的
就喜歡有長的人在那邊抱著
如果有人那時候跟著一起
對
對 把籌碼丟出來
你就難搞了
對 全台灣都做短
那我們就沒得做了好不好
對 那會很難做
所以感谢古瑜老师
我发现你们两个
站在我们的对面
心心相喜
真的吗
他现在也有在做短
在他的系列
就是那个
存古debug可以看一下
做短的
他不是老师跟人家讲
要天长地久吗
他跟你两个搭档
一段时间之后
他就偷偷告诉我
他灵魂有一部分
已经跟你融合了
这样子哦
对
他本来说要给人家幸福
后来不是要给人家幸福
应该讲天长地久给的是幸福
他现在做短的给的是什么
舒服
好 谢谢古瑜
你还被黄标
但是我们今天的重点来了
刚刚讲的那个主题实在是很难
赵华从来没这样做过
怎么样能够全台湾第一个领导股息
第一个领导股息
对 这不可思议
大家不是一样的时间领导吗
先给你看我的亏钱对账单
今天决定秀亏钱对账单
很多人都会说
小哥你老是拿赚钱的
给你看亏钱的
早就猜到你是有两个户头
一个有赚就一直拿出来
网友很好笑
我们上次贴一排对账单
小哥你这个对账单
一定是两边对坐
对 一边多一边空
一边坐空
我说那一坨拉股股票
我的有的多有的空
对
那我两边对坐
我怎么去选择一边全部赚钱
另外一边全部赔钱了
就是用那个批图啦
除非批图嘛
以前还真的有人批图你知道吗
那个荣卷卖出啊
荣卷卖出
郑欣卷出
郑欣卷
他写荣卷卖出
批图还把那个字给批错
被人家笑好久
荣卷卖出
以为是吃小卷的
那你以为是亏钱对账男朋友
华欣哥真的亏
本来就亏钱对上单啊
创意19口
哇 亏惨了
亏14万1耶
小钱啦 对小哥来说
怎么亏那么多呢
但是亏就是亏
训了嘛
训了 没有啦
你看一下底下有
这个6月1号嘛
一找我的这个户头里面呢
就多了
各位看一下
1万1万加加加加
这一家呢是19万
19万
买方权艺术家项
对
全艺术加项
因为我买的是创意
创意6月1号除息
配5块
配5块我是用股票期货去买
去参加
那股票期货一口两张
两张配5块就是一口我可以配到1万
所以它那么快就入账了
一早就入账
还不用缴税
不用缴健保补充费
什么
对是这样子
完全一出家就要现金鼓励
你振兴劝不要领给我了
你不需要
真的啊
我要啊
你不要的话我收
1450收好不好
1450太少了啦
好
所以到底怎么做到的
怎么做到的咧
好来来
我是全台湾六月份
第一个领股息的男人
全台湾第一个最有出息的男人
最有出息
拿到息了嘛
出息给你了嘛
对对对
6月1号上8点30分
股力就入账了
还没开盘
交易损失
当天这样一买一卖
上面写赔14万1
所以你的个股期
其实是赔钱的
对 因为在账面上是赔钱的
因为我是买在232左右
卖在227.5
所以一共赔了14万1
但是现金股力是19万
总计获利4万9
4万9
对
那这个就是用股票起货来做
怎么做到的
我买现股可以吗
买现股也可以
我们今天会跟各位讲
现股怎么用
因为我知道股票期货杠杆比较大
赚比较快
可是有些人对期货没那么在行会怕
所以现股也可以
现股也可以
但现股它的费用比较高
对啦
因为它要准备的钱比较多
对
股票期货你可以平常不要玩
你就套利的时候玩
除全息的时候玩
股票起货最害怕什么你知道吗
最害怕你看它不爽你去空
这种是最害怕的交易
因为你看它涨那么多去空它
那被嘎翻了
最怕这种
其他的都不大会怕
所以我们先用现股来举例来看创意其实我前几天就有玩嗯所以幾幾天我價差就有賺到了所以你的意思是除全息錢的前幾天
對
你就用個股期再玩了
對 因為個股期有個好處啦
對
它的交易成本很低
是
所以呢
我只要例如說
230買
230.5賣
對
都有賺錢
但是小哥這個的話
用個股期才有辦法達到效果
因為它非常短進
短出
这边价差有做到
然后在6月1号开盘的时候
它涨1.3%就可以卖了
就可以卖了
1.3%就可以卖了
玩股票涨1.3%
你卖了还要缴0.3%的交易税
没感觉1.3%
你还要缴你所得税
急剧高的还要缴所得税
对
你要缴健保补充费
你要缴手续费
对
一堆费用
没错
你会觉得赚没多少
是
帮政府打工
但是你用股票期望
這1.3%事實上你就賺很多了
因為它交易成本相對低很多
所以因為它是6月1號做的
所以你號稱6月1號
6月也是第一個全台灣最早零股息的人
第一個拿到股息的男人
我一早就拿到了
好 一早就拿到了
那為什麼我敢玩創意呢
沒錯 現在重點就是你怎麼選到他的
為什麼 來吧 講講這就是我的東西
好 創意呢 這個我們看
创意
它配现金股利5块
然后当天创意上涨几率有60%
平均涨1.3%
这是历年来的统计
历年是多长
历年来大概10年
10年
10年统计
60%上涨
可是它历年几乎
我们看这里有当日开处理昨天收
几乎它当天开盘都是上涨的
只有一两次是开平盘
平盘
OK
还不是下跌是平盘
没错
因为这种除旋径
大部分都很容易开高
那为什么很容易
后面有的杀回去
因为太多人玩全证了
因为他前一天买全证
堵他开高
然后隔天赶快卖掉
对 也是你
对
我们这个有全证也会玩全证
有期货就玩期货
我发现他上涨几率
在两天前有八成
对 也很高
当日也有六成
你只要看到这两天前很高
你也可以提早布局
所以像小哥刚刚就讲说
两天前你也有在玩他的价差
没错
即便创意他这阵子的筹码不好
对
可是我们玩除悬席还是有赚到
所以这一档就是套用上次我们讲的
你玩前面也玩后面
玩前面玩后面
对
玩前面
今天好像讲得比较自在一点
对啊
因为上次已经讲过一遍了
没有别的人在旁边就对了
古鱼不会在那边假倒雪
在旁边装听不懂
对啊
好 那我们看这个除息日呢
你可以用个股期做
你也可以用现股做
好 但是现股的话
就是它那个价差比较
没有那么有感觉
对 好 我们看一下
你假如买177万的现股
对
股息呢 大概3.85万
价差赔7700
然后呢 这个手续交易税
又赔8000%
这个所得税我们还不算
因为每个人税的急剧不一样
所以没算到
股息这个健保股充费770
总共你大概赚2万1
你假如用这个
等于也是用创意做例子
对不对
你在前天买231
隔天开高你就229卖掉
然后他配一个5块钱会进来
配5块钱进来
你大概可以赚2万1
但是你假如用各股息后来做的话
这个股息有19万
价差赔7万6
手续交易税
看每个人
每个人这个数字不大一样
有40 50 60 不一定
对
股息补充保费没有
没有
总共可以赚到11万
差了大概5倍
5倍多
对啊
所以这个用期货来做
相对来得好一些
所以真的很保守
像赵华这样
目前不太敢去做期货的
限股也可以
可是它的获益率就比较低一点
可是同样的道理可以同样用
没错
好 那股票期货呢
我大概介绍一下
还是介绍一下
很多人都不熟
而且一听到期货就很担心
是不是要一直盯
欠家荡产的
需不需要一直盯呢
看你保证金放多少
那我可不可以跟小哥私底下
说请小哥帮我盯呢
帮你那叫代操吗
代操是非法的
所以不行
好
自己学起来
那股票期货又叫做个股期货
是用股票为标的的期货商品
那一般股票期货
我们都是用一口一口来寄
一口是2000股
各股其他有一个优点
交易时间上午8点45分开始
到下午1点45分
比我们的股票开盘还要长半小时
所以当天创意
我还没等创意开盘
我就先卖掉一些
可是卖不一定好
因为搞不好开盘高
因为在戳耳的时候
看到价格都乱跳
对
我们常常都说
戳合吓死人
对
开盘笑死人
戳合涨停板
我真的有学会
因为上次小哥说
戳合的时候
如果涨停板不是好事
不是好事
我后来天天观察
大部分都要出货的
完全跟你讲的一样
对
真的
戳合涨停板就两种
一个真的涨停的
假如没有涨停
那就是要出货的
我观察到现在90%
戳合涨停的开盘没有
戳合涨停开盘没有
当天容易黑K
对
常常都这样
因为主力要诱使你去买股票
还用错额涨停来骗你
到期月份7月就要
只到下午1点半而已
第三个礼拜三
第三个礼拜三只到下午1点半
其他可以到1点45
交易时间这样
你可以比别人早卖
早卖
也可以晚买晚卖
赚很开心
可是如果说它跌个2、3%
你得到的风险也是很高的
还是要提醒风险
个股期风险真的很大
一般玩个股期我们都建议
你钱不要入太多
小赌移情
个股期跟股票不一样
股票是你今天买了两天后
找钱出来交割就可以
个股期是你一早要入金
所以我们都说你入金不要入太多
不要入太多
你入太多很容易下太大
入太多就很容易心太大
对不对
没错
个股期要
我跟你讲古鱼在
另外一集存股迪霸
大家可以看
它其实有两个户头
一个户头其实像小哥讲的
你可以去做一些
比较灵活的交易
因为这个比较符合人性
如果你的交易都一直在存股的话
你会闷掉
对
他自己也想到这件事
所以他也喜欢玩短的
所以他就是跟你你知道
对
外表这样子
怎么私底下做得好像不是
我现在发现我在你们两个中间
我是第三者
你是第三者
你们两个已经
我们两个都一样的
天人合一了
天人合一
好的
好
那这个重点
我们是要找除全息日容易涨的标的
这就很重要
因为刚刚讲说
假设我挑错了
结果除全息它反而跌下去
我用个股期我风险高
所以我现在要提高我的胜率
对
我一定要找到它会涨的
没错
好
会涨有几个条件
我先找第一个
第一個叫主力5日籌碼集中度大於5%
這聽起來有點難
我們當然會做比較詳細的解釋
不用
不用自己算
有軟體可以給你看
我們還是會教大家怎麼算
但是不用自己算
第二個除息當天歷史開高機率高
這可能也要教我們去哪邊找對這個我有設計都有設計的第個呢有配發股票鼓勵更好第三個很重要這個很重要
這個我們在之前也講過
小哥會教你玩有股票鼓勵的
不是現金鼓勵喔
是股票鼓勵
現金鼓勵你要配很多的
配很多的還可以啦
配一點點就比較沒有
好
那第四個呢
除全其日
開高就賣掉
只玩當天
只玩当天一早
对
玩城跑
跑三升
前一天什么时候买都可以吗
前一天什么时候买都可以
我们建议你可以两天前买
两天前买
那假如两天前买
隔天有赚到
你也可以出一些
好 两天前买
如果除全席
你有两次获利的机会
两次获利的机会
等于说两天前买
前一天有高
可以卖一趟
如果没有
就等除全席
当天
开高把它卖掉
那我也没开高你
你也是要挺損
没开高就要挺高
不然它尾盘会拉起来
你可以拗看看
可以拗一下
因为尾盘就拼人品
尾盘拼人品
对 尾盘拼人品
早盘拼准备
早盘拼 对
因为很多历史上都很容易开高
好
我们今天特别准备了好几档
历史上容易开高的
太棒了
所以我们连标的小哥
等一下都会帮我们介绍看看
有帮你们搞一下
好的
OK
所以你刚刚有讲到这个
主力五日筹码集中度大于5%
看到数学我们会害怕
来 没关系
现在呢
数字会害怕的
我们有图形给你看
图形就比较不怕了吧
这个就是符合所谓的主力
好 主力五日筹码集中度大于5%
好 那就是最近主力有在买的意思
这五天主力有在买
筹码集中度大于5%
这一档算是一个范例
没错像东阳这个有开高
这是有开高的
因为除息股价有掉下来
但是它是有开高
那为什么要最近主力有在买
因为你不一定是在前一天进场
你有可能前两天
你有可能前三天
你至少进场的时候
不要被主力倒货
你进场被主力倒货
那股价跌了那就赔钱
所以你先找主力最近有在买的你进场
你有可能主力先帮你抬轿一下
那在除息当天开高
那就把它卖掉
立刻把它卖掉
卖掉更好
这是东洋
所以有主力卡位的话
除息日是容易开高的
对
因为主力有在买
其实也是筹码相对稳定
对不对
没错
筹码相对稳定
来看下一档华通
华通在这阵子
虽然它慢慢的缓跌
但是你看一下
主力还是有在买
对
主力有在买
这当天也是开高
然后一下子就填息了
那你假如摆个一两天
因为滑通历年也容易填息
你想说我要赌填息也可以
你也不一定当天一早都要卖
你等个一两天后面填息
你整个股息都赚到
那你假如是股票期货的话
当天股息都配给你
个股的话股息可能要等半个月一个月
对所以股票期货真的是很夸张
一配就发给你了
还不用扣税
没错
不公平
对啊
可是呢
政府这样对旗交所比较好
那证交所怎么办呢
我们再讲几次
可能国税局就去抗议了
你怎么可以再讲这个
不用扣税这种事情
对
可是事实上
这个期货我们这样讲
期货你去买还是会有点问题
我怕这个节目收视率太好
对 点阅率太高
点阅率太高导致怎么样了
導致在除全息前
每個人都跑去買
你放心絕對不會
我很害怕
因為小哥教我的
哥有酬必爆第一集教什麼
我現在已經快忘光了
三根K線我還有去看
好像已經37萬人
超受歡迎的一集
超受歡迎 對啊
因為我也是因為這一集
我才對K棒到底怎麼看
紅K黑K
我才會看耶
真的喔
對
然後上影線下影線怎麼看
我现在才会看
应该要弄个字卡在左上角
记得再去点那个影片
没错
要开始教这个了
主力五日筹码集中度
这个其实也蛮简单的
这个是算是
我们把买方前15名
近5天的总买超量
好
就买超量前15名
前15大的买家
对
这5天的前15大买家
扣掉前15大的卖家
再除以近五天的总成交量
对 这所有的买家
对不对
所有的买卖家
对 所有的成交
然后前15名的买家去减
前15名的卖家
没错
这15名就算蛮有意义的
对
因为全台湾分点有900个
那我们要求呢
这个至少大于5%
5%
5%代表主力有在买
好 5%就是上面这15名非常强
买很多
5%就很多了
好 5%就很多了
那5%呢
你说这样算很困难
沒關係
給你看一個
而且你要去搜15大買家賣家
很麻煩
這很簡單
你只要去下載一個
籌碼K線APP
小哥的招牌
用手機就可以
下載了
例如說我們看創意
再看主力
你先找創意
你看一下
它午日集中度
很差
對啊
那不是跟剛剛講的不一樣
我跟你講
因為它很差
所以我才買19口
它很好我就买100口了
对啊 因为它很差
所以我就买一点点买19口就好
好 虽然它的历史记录
因为你有先修它历史记录嘛
对
等于是说它除全前
它的那个开高纪律很高
很高
对 除全前它还有一段
甚至可以做价差的
对
所以你喜欢它
可惜主力不够集中
对
那我最近主力买很多
我那天会下很大
好 所以它很多条件里面
主力的它的条件其实相对比较弱
所以你就小买一点
但是它还是验证了
还是赚钱了
因为除全息就这么迷人
它赚钱几率就是很高
所以用这个方法还是有赚到
瑕疵品还是有赚到
对
这个5%的相信会赚更多
好 那你等一下应该会准备
没有瑕疵的吧
这个昨天制作人有问我
小哥你可不可以帮我们找
最近要除息
那五日主力也很好的
我刚刚讲
最近很多股票要除息
但是呢
但是怎么样
但是五日主力
你要看它几号除息
看它前五天
比如说七月底的
你只能等到七月二十号附近
开始观察主力状况
所以制作人出了一个功课
他要过去的填息几率好
他要除全息前也会涨
他还要主力筹码集中度大于5%的
所以制作人完全遗傳自我的真傳給他了
他要直接要答案
直接要答案
我們慢慢的來給答案
我們慢慢來給答案
剛剛那張表我們就在談笑間過了
沒有螢幕照相的人就是沒有照到啦
對啊 我們還是要留點給精英班的同學
精英班要誠摯歡迎小哥來幫我們講解
放一點點福利給他們
好 我們先來講
剛剛那張表裡面
看到的我们制作人的要求
没错
我们先来看今年高配股的题材
高配股题材像中朱
他现金股利配了4.6
股票股利配0.4
有配股票股利的都很不错
对 即使他是0.4
他不是说都配股票但他有配他有配这年头有配股票股利就很好了就很好那我们再来看它当天上涨几率有75%
这个软体叫做
个股事件行情大解密
是我设计的
个股行情事件大解密
可能要请后市上
个股事件行情大解密
还与收期就对了
这个是我专门在收集这些统计资料
可不可以不要取那么难记的名字
真的吗
要不然取什么
买这个一定赚
好
金管会会来
不能这样子
因为我们是在做统计而已
这个他当天上涨几率高
然后他当天开高的几率也很高
这到了87.5%
非常高
对
十次有8.7次
常常都在講87%沒有再更高了
87分87分
對87%沒有再
這個我們大概還有比87%還高的
那幾乎100%了嘛
比87%還高
對歷年來都是開高的
但我們可以看到它的特色是
它兩天前其實不太會動
一天前會動
當日也會動
當天就漲了
隔天也漲
對隔天也漲
所以你假如還想
凹一下 凹隔天也可以
就如果他后来当日不如预期
也许隔天还有机会
对 都要看他历史的一个惯性
没错 好
不过还是要跟各位讲
这是历史的统计
有可能今年刚好
隔天遇到怎么样
美股跌1000点
他有可能也会跌
所以没有百分之百的
但是我们是提供历史经验给你参考
大家可以列入自选股观察
中租 这个也是好公司
好 接下来看
另外一檔叫中壽
都是中自备
中壽今年配0.6块股票鼓励
也是有配股票鼓励
当天开盘开高上涨几率有71%
很高 七成
也蛮高的
但是当天上涨几率只剩28%
这要怎么判断
这代表一开盘要赶快跑
有没有看到
一开盘有71%开高
对 它很容易开高走低
没错
这个软体的珍贵支出就在这边
告诉你有的可以凹两天
有的开高赶快跑
有的只能凹10分钟
只能凹10分钟
看你撑多久
你在讲股票行情什么事件
个股事件行情大解密
好
个股事件对对对
太难了啦
好 再录关键时刻
对
关键时刻
好 再来看
鱼鱼的最爱
玉山金
是不是
我就说你有注意它的爱
玉山金今年也配得不错
0.8块股票鼓励
有些金控股还蛮特别
玉山金就是很喜欢配股票的
对自己的成长有信心
对
信息鼓励也0.79
我们看一下
历年来66.7%上涨
3分之2的几率
平均只要上涨
涨2.5%
很多
很多人都喜欢玩玉山金
初宣席就这样
很值得一玩
最近涨不少
金融股
最近这行情很怪
很多感觉都已经涨到北风北了
昨天已经涨到友达群创了
又打第二圈
之前涨到莱德中环
就觉得这不是北风北了
现在还有友达群创可以涨
我现在学会了
友达群创是在
中環萊德的后面
对
现在我们不能说它是
就是鸡蛋水饺股
鸡蛋水饺股
对
中環萊德已经超越友达群创了
好
但是这些股票我们要讲了
因为小哥有讲
你要除全息前
你才能去观察
它的筹码集中度
我现在没办法观察
现在没办法观察
因为每一家除全息日不同
所以现在小哥是把历史几率告诉你
已经有一个参考值了
可是快要除全息前
前五六天
请去看他的主力的筹码集中度
好不好
小哥的APP
好
来 接下来看
今年高配股的题材
好
华汉
好 华汉
红海集团小金基
股票股力配到一块
是
但是but
but
最重要的
可是我们喜欢念but
but大家觉得比较有趣一点
我被我英文家教老师纠正
真的喔
but
我是老师被我儿子纠正
你那蔡
蔡德英文
可不可以不要讲
当天他上去只剩33%
很少耶
当天开盘只剩50%上涨
那你选他做什么
这种也是要提醒各位
总不能全部讲好的
他是负面表列
對 有的股票鼓勵配得多
對
可是歷年來
這個沒有配股票鼓勵的時候
它常常沒有開很高
可是這次有配股票鼓勵你要小心
因為它之前有配過
可是當天它還是怎麼樣
跌
所以有些公司不要只看它配股票鼓勵
你就覺得它很好
然後這邊的話
小哥其實有非常的佛心
也非常的暗扛了一些東西
對
就是為什麼要給我們的
精英班同學
其實小哥手上還有一些是
過去配席 填席機率非常好的
可是這個可能會留在
精英班來跟你說
為什麼呢 因為小哥非常難得
他常常來我們精英班做直播
也線上幫大家回答問題
他希望大家真的來支持
我們這個佛心的頻道
因為小哥在外面其實也開班授課
可是他在達人秀
這麼無私的
用這麼低的價錢
來跟你線上互動
還保留那麼多好的個股
要在精英班來跟你做討論
那這邊正好也要謝謝很多
支持我们基因班的朋友们
例如说像于明哲
明哲也常常来基因班
跟我们互动
你问的每一个问题
我们都让你有没有
得到最充分的解答
所以谢谢你明哲
然后温大宝
温大宝说赵华
我真的觉得你主持超棒
还说理化就是理解
别人说的话说得很好
所以小哥说的话
你是不是都能理解
如果不能理解
欢迎来基因班
跟我们多互动
还有杨志超智慧超人
他说有种感恩
所有制作这个节目的人
不管镜头前跟镜头后
镜头后就是我们制作团队
他们现在都站在这个里面
跟我们一起来把这个节目做好
然后会给我们很多打pass
讲太久了啦
讲这个不能讲
讲了尽管会不会来
然后照好头发掉下来
对 所以我们镜头后
有很多的无名英雄
也是要谢谢他们
好 那今天也谢谢小哥
来参与我们今天的
歌有仇必报的录制
那不要忘记
我们的小哥在金星班
也会常常直播跟大家来碰面
一定要来问问题
那因为今年的除全席行情
看起来非常热
那赵华要提醒
你喜欢做场真的没有关系
你可以学古鱼那一套
去等天席
那你喜欢做短
小哥真的教了很多
很棒的方法
你可以除全席前两天
就去布局
你可以前一天有卖到价差
你甚至也可以后一天
去赚那个开高的那段钱
那小哥也教你
你喜欢玩线古就买线古
但是杠杆要放大的话
个股期会是一个好选择
有任何问题欢迎留言给我们
那我們今天的歌有抽必爆理財大人秀
就到這邊囉
Bye Bye